totally get creative and vehicles
responding vehicles recovering very
nicely on the liftoff transient August
fourth 2007 @ 526 am this Delta two
rocket blasts off from Cape Canaveral in
its nose cone is NASA's first robotic
Mars Scout the Phoenix lander but this
point we have a strong signal from
Phoenix priority
at NASA's Jet Propulsion Laboratory in
Pasadena California engineers monitor
the progress of the half-billion dollar
mission haut stations differ from state
separation and USF single expedition
valued Odyssey at the store again she on
my mark 321 mark the new generation
lander enters the final phase of its 400
million mile journey to Mars one minute
in LOL standing by physical reactivation
phoenix will search the Arctic plains of
Mars for the building blocks of life
including carbon nitrogen and most
importantly water touched on detective
planet sequence initiated Phoenix
intends to prove that life on Mars is or
was possible
if it does then life on earth is not
unique
this is a test simulation but this
afternoon the team at JPL did this for
real today Phoenix entered the
atmosphere of Mars primary objective of
Phoenix is to explore the Martian Arctic
and to determine whether or not
conditions for life are there today and
are existed in the past if Phoenix finds
what it's looking for it will change our
understanding of the solar system if
there's life on another world it could
mean that the universe is teeming with
it that the aliens of our science
fiction could be a reality
Phoenix might even find them but finding
the signs of life on a planet millions
of miles from home is an incredibly
difficult challenge the lander hasn't
been designed to find life directly it's
been built to find the necessary
ingredient for it water Chris McKay is a
planetary scientist at NASA's Ames
Research Center when we look at life on
Earth we see an enormous diversity
organisms that do all sorts of different
chemistry live in all sorts of different
environments but the one thing that all
organisms on Earth have in common is a
requirement for liquid water so
naturally when we look for life
elsewhere we start first by looking for
environments that liquid water